こんにちは　Dr.はじめだ
お前たち
興味深い物を見つけた
こちらです
恐竜発掘
ヒトカゲ、トリケラトプス、キリンリキ、フシギダネ
なんと砂の中から恐竜が出てくるらしいです
こっちと
こっちで計12人だな
ま、計じゅに人の中
ま、計12人
ま、計じゅに人の
ま、計じゅに人の中から
じゅうににん
ま、計12人の中からバカ1人が出てくるというわけだ
超簡単です
なんか開けて
開けると中に砂が入ってて
そっから発掘するらしいです
僕も詳しいことはわかんないんですけども
ま、僕はね恐竜博士と呼ばれていてね
ま、恐竜に関してはねもうジュラ紀から白亜紀までね
なんでも分かってます
まぁまあまあアンモナイトとかもね
しょっちゅうね食事に出ますよ
うん
じゃあ開けてみましょう
これはね誰かが動画で出してたね
あ～こんな感じでございます
ブラシとヘラですね
これを使って砂から化石を発掘するということになります
はい出ました
こちらです
お砂でございます
このお砂の中に
さっきのバカ12人の中から1人バカが入ってるというわけで
あーこれ部屋がすごいことになりそうだな
なにか敷きましょう
なんかもうドンキの人みたいになっちゃうけどいい
ドンドンドンキーでも敷いときます
早速開けてみましょう
こん中にバカが入ってるんだよな
すげー
なんかガチモンだね
これ食べれるのかなー？
食べれたら嬉しい
あー食べちゃダメなんだ
これがね角砂糖とかだったら最高にハッピーなんだよな
じゃあ早速やってみようと思います
あははははははは
( ^)o(^ )
～＾ED＾～
ま、化学技術ですよ
今の最先端の技術を使えばこんなのも一発で手に入ります
ティラノサウルス？
え、待って
これティラノサウルスか？
ティラノサウルスじゃね？
ティラノサウルスか？
え、当たりじゃん
ティラノサウルス？
ちげーよ、マシュンガドロスじゃん
というわけで割と結構可愛いです
実は俺
結構恐竜も好きなんです
是非普通にやってみてください
じゃあな！